so what's your like your overarching
opinion so far like dabbling into this
community
um so
i actually thought that your channel was
the most accurate one that i could find
as a girl because there's just certain
things that i've always liked disagreed
with in the manosphere just like from
like talking to friends my age and like
i don't know just hearing like the girls
side of things um like i think i
when i emailed you i said like the men
age like fine wine argument i've
literally like
i've never agreed with that i don't know
any friends that like date older
intentionally
so that's an interesting point because a
lot of i'll definitely say mgtow and to
some extent red pill
uh like believers would argue that men
do age
more like fine wine they believe that
a lot of men reach their peak smv like
late into their 30s or even 40s uh so
would you disagree with that
um i mean i could maybe see the argument
for like early 30s but i think of like
the guys i went to college with and
other guys like i know like most of them
don't look better in their 30s than
their 20s
so
so you're saying that it is just looks
but what about the superior status that
these men in their 30s and 40s may hold
like their superior jobs more money like
do you factor that into account or are
you just going based off looks
um i i think it starts with looks
but i don't think a guy that's like 5'4
5'3 can really like buy his way into the
high status
okay so so height is like a requirement
so i'm gonna be quite uh nitpicky here
and uh just just go straight to the
d-pad view so
what is like your height cut off i'm not
sure how tall you are but like just
going based off um
like how you look now probably guess
you're about five nine five ten
i'm six foot
you're six foot oh okay so is it like a
requirement for you for a man to be over
six foot um so i would say i'm a little
less picky than most girls i'd say five
ten
um but like i clearly would prefer
taller the better like my boyfriend is
six three
oh okay
that's interesting so
just theoretically if a man was 510 per
say like
would he need to be making up for it in
other areas so like if you said your
minimum was 510 like you need to have a
better face compared to another option
who's six foot two
yeah honestly yeah
um okay that's that makes sense uh an
interesting point that you talked about
in the email like short email exchange
we had was that
both men and women
like are finding difficult difficulty in
the dating market right now so obviously
i talk mostly about the difficulties
that men face however you also alluded
to the difficulties that women face
and you touched on the points that it
sounded like you was taking the side
that
although women
have easy access to intimacy through
a medium such as online dating they're
struggling in terms of relationships so
it's often coined the term that uh men
are the gatekeepers of relationships
whether that is true or not hopefully
we'll discuss that even further
so like is that like what you was trying
to allude to like do you think pretty
much do you think there is a black bill
for women
um
yes yeah i do i think um that like a guy
would there's a certain level of like
attractiveness that he would date or
hook up with but he would never like be
with publicly
um do you think that
for a woman
are you a woman can get a relationship
with a man of greater looks than he is
even if it's like by a point or two well
when i think of like what a girl has to
do to increase her smv i think it's like
easier than what a guy has to do to
increase his smv so a girl might have
like a five face but she could increase
her smb by being like fit feminine and
like friendly right like i kind of agree
with that notion and maybe get like a
six or seven but a guy has to like work
for five years to increase his income by
20k
or like 30k whatever it is so that's
like harder to do
or um possibly like learn game increases
social status whatever it is and i think
those are all incredibly harder things
to do than like what a girl has to do
yeah yeah okay but but i think like
but i think like if a girl is like a
five
and like wanted to get a nine i don't
really think i think that's
i don't know if that's possible where if
a guy's a five he could become a
billionaire and get a nine
but that's like that's the my problem
with the manosphere is they talk about
in screen in extremes but like there
it's very rare that a guy becomes a
billionaire or a millionaire that's not
common yeah i have two points with that
i have heard that argument quite a lot
my first point is like similar to what
you said that when we're talking about
this guy becoming a billionaire and
being able to attract a nine despite him
being a five like this is by far like
less than
0.01 of the population that is actually
going to be able to you know attract a
woman by that uh avenue like the
majority of people aren't going to
become a billionaire or a rockstar or a
famous person it just doesn't appeal to
the like 99.9 of average people
so would you agree with that
yeah i agree with you and the second
point i have this is a bit more
interesting that
when you do see these cases of a
billionaire five
uh being able to attract a nine out of
ten supermodel
would you say that like the love is
genuine like would you say that the
woman is actually in love with the uh
man or is she only there for the
resources that he can provide
um yeah
it wouldn't seem to be genuine it seems
like if the money went um she would go
too
yeah yeah so so she's only there for
like the resources that you can find and
what about have you ever seen the cases
of i'm not sure how much of my content
you have watched but like observing
women's body language
uh
which shows that but the woman is not
actually interested in the man so like
if a woman like refuses to like hold a
rich man's hand or something something
along those lines then
it shows that there isn't a genuine
interest there
um that's that stuff is really
interesting to me but i haven't seen
those videos
um oh okay fair enough the one the one
video i saw which i actually
was curious what you think um
shoot sorry um
the video i saw of yours was neil
strauss where he attracted that model
yeah yeah so that's a good example so
obviously neil strauss has a lot of
money um he's arguably high status to an
extent like he's you know a author so
and he was partially able to attract
that one because of that so would you
so would you say that that is like a
genuine level
uh well see i actually agreed with you
until i looked into it more he cheated
on her
oh really
yeah i'm not i'm not aware of like the
whole situation but
like the
from the face value of it like
what my interpretation was like
obviously i didn't read a huge amount of
it so i'm not sure what to what extent
that that would have had on the
relationship
or even further like this is just
speculation right now but
is it possible that
the man uh neil strauss wasn't get
getting uh his needs satisfied um from
this woman and therefore he might have
felt a need to cheat because in all
honesty if if they was um having
intimacy five times a week then i don't
think that he he may have like felt a
need to to go out and cheat
um that's a good point i never thought
about it like that that's possible yeah
yeah well like the point that i've made
in the video like obviously just looking
at the face value that
um this man significantly below the
women's looks level like ended up
divorcing in five years so when you do
see these
so-called outliers of a man being
significantly below
uh the women's looks level
then
the relationships are often volatile and
the
uh yeah so it usually ends up breaking
down prematurely
yeah no i definitely agree with that
that was actually why i liked your
channel so much i've never seen someone
like break down the looks chart like you
did and that just seemed to be the most
like accurate way i've seen
what like i think it all starts with
looks even for girls and guys will say
that's not true
yeah and i would say that it's a lot
harder for men to pass the
looks like barrier that women like hold
up like the standards that they hold
like 99 of the time
the man is gonna re rejected hurdle one
which is looks and i think that a lot of
the time the red pill community in
particular focuses too much on uh what
happens after you've
captured a woman's interest but i think
that there is less spoken about on
actually um
passing the first looks threshold that
women face because that is where most
men are getting weeded out
yeah well i think
i don't think women care as much about
like like facial symmetry so to speak
but i think height is just so big for
women like women do not want to be with
a guy that's shorter than them so if you
get a guy that's shorter than the
average girl
it's going to be really tough for him to
find a relationship
so that's going to be quite problematic
so did you obviously like you're a tall
girl yourself so would you like place
higher uh
height to a higher degree than maybe
shorter girls because you often hear the
phrase uh you know like a five-foot
woman will say oh as long as the guy is
taller than me while i'm wearing heels
that suggests that a man who is five
foot four or five foot five like has a
chance he's is he's in with a chance uh
do you think there's truth to that
yeah um i would say i mean i think
shorter girls when given the choice
they're gonna pick a taller guy like no
matter what height they're at
um but if i was gonna give a short guy
dating advice i i probably would suggest
he goes after the shorter girls to have
the best chance but is his height still
gonna play a factor
yeah
like of course yeah of course of course
yeah there's amples of data to back that
up um in fact i've actually got a chart
it's interesting you brought up that
point i just found it's quite
interesting because
have you you sharing my screen right now
yeah so this like this chart measured
the number of messages that both men and
women receive uh on i believe the dating
site okay cupid's it might be tinder i'm
not i'm not too sure
and you can see so men receive the most
messages around
six anywhere between six one and the
latter peak is around six five so like
this is like the ideal range uh but like
there is a massive drop-off for men
after around 5 10 like once you're below
5 10 that is when the steepest shift
happens
but what you notice is that when you
look at the chart for women
their height isn't really problematic
until
you reach like five foot 11 and onwards
that's when like a steep drop-off
happens but all the heights from four
foot eight to five foot ten like five
foot eleven sorry
that that is like quite consistent like
men don't see that as an issue
yeah i haven't really i haven't had a
problem um
like i've never had a guy say that he
didn't like my height ever
if anything like when i first saw this
graph my explanation for it like the
drop-off would be men not would it be
willing to approach the woman because
they aren't tall enough for her
rather than the woman being tall too
tall for him
uh because based on my experience like i
don't think a like a woman's height has
a significant um
factor on her attractiveness if anything
i actually believe that women who are
taller like five foot eleven uh six foot
six foot one are more attractive hence
why there is a such high concentration
of uh those types of models in the like
industry like they're usually much
taller but would i approach one probably
not because i'll be i'd say that i'm
more likely to approach women in the
like five foot four five foot five sort
of range or lower because that who is
like i probably have a stronger chance
with
no i definitely agree with you um i was
like because i've played sports my whole
life most of my friends are 5 10 and up
so i even have a friend that's six five
that got married to a guy that's six
seven
so
like i don't you say six five to six
seven yeah
see this is interesting because
i think
it is even if a woman is tall like let's
you know say six five
i don't think that she will have many
issues
finding a partner who is still taller
than her like even though it is
extremely rare but for men who are
significantly below average height like
five foot six or five foot four even
it's unlikely that they'll be able to
find a
uh girlfriend easily who is five foot
like she's likely still going to reject
him
well and that's what the man of sphere
doesn't really talk about like they act
like any guy can just become a quote
unquote high value man
and i don't think it's in the cards for
all guys
yeah yeah and and obviously like as the
data we've seen here yeah suggest that i
want to move on to something else
because i think
uh this is quite interesting so like
we've both got like a reasonably idea of
reasonable idea of where we go at the
moment
what do you think of
this
i came across this a couple weeks ago i
just found it hilarious
what's your thoughts
i'm so lonely
um no that's real that's true i would
say uh
but i think when a girl accepts a date
with a guy she's looking more for like a
long-term relationship or a husband
where i if a guy accepts a date with a
girl i i think they're less picky
because
you know they want sex more more so than
a relationship
not not all guys but i would say like
like you know at the end of the day if a
guy gets like late he'll go on a date
with someone you know so what's your
opinion on you know the the good old
phrase that men are the gatekeepers to
relationships when like women
or women are getting like date proposals
and
why are they refusing to date those men
uh probably because they're not
attracted to them
for whatever reason whether it's like
social status height
looks whatever it is
so would that imply that women are the
gatekeepers of relationships rather than
the other way around
because they're
refusing to comply
um
see that's hard because i i can't say
that because men are the ones that ask
like they're the ones that get on their
knee they're the ones that hold the key
like a girl's never gonna i would say
rarely is gonna ask a guy to be your
boyfriend or ask a guy to marry her
but if we're talking about like a
genuine date like the man's not asking
for a hookup like or anything like that
i'd say the man like when a man asks a
asks a woman on a date there's probably
like a 10 to 20 chance she's going to
comply and say yes
yeah but i would agree so
in the like 80 to 90 of the time that
the woman is like rejecting the man like
that's her in control like that's her in
power and by the definition of a date
like i think that's implying there is
the potential to have a relationship
there like if a man wanted intimacy from
a woman then he's likely just going to
ask uh do you want to just hook up right
now i i doubt that if a man's asking for
a date he's looking for intimacy he
might be but like not anywhere near to
the extent
um
yeah i guess i could see how you could
make that argument
so based on that like uh if women are
the if women are the ones who are
turning down date proposals from men
like such as what this image shows yeah
yeah then would that imply that women
are the gatekeepers of relationships
rather than the other way around
um
that's a that's a good point um
yeah i guess
i just i have a hard time saying that
because again like men hold the key to
marriage so that's probably why i still
wouldn't say that um but i think with
like a guys
below their league so to speak yeah they
hold the
gatekeeper to relationships
so
would i be correct in saying that you're
backtracking on the statement that men
are the
gatekeepers to relationship but rather
that it keeps their marriage
hmm
yeah actually yeah that would make more
sense
so yeah that's that's a interesting
argument
but like i i would say that it's less so
if a woman so if a man and a woman is in
a relationship
i think that like a woman you know like
she she's happy she's content now like i
don't think that she's going to be upset
the fact that uh he's not willing to
propose and if anything the
man is likely not going to want to go
that extra step and get married because
of the potential repercussions i'm not
sure how much you know about um
like divorce courts and um
like the the implications of
how that can be devastating for a man's
uh financial life in particular
um so so what's your thoughts on that
um
yeah i'll put a question this way so if
a
man refuses to or so so to say like
refuses by just delaying it uh the
wanting to get married is that because
he's not um like willing to commit fully
or is it because he's concerned about
these external factors
such as um
you know the issues with divorce divorce
courts
um
so i mean i haven't
i i can't really give you a definitive
answer because i don't know um i just
know like what i've seen and i have like
brothers right that have been dating
their girlfriends for like three four
years and i just know that they wouldn't
marry them until they twist their arm
and make them do it but i don't think it
has anything to do with money
i think some guys like just don't want
to commit long term
like it's kind of scary for them to
commit one girl for the rest of their
lives
i don't think three to four years is
like
that um a long period of relationship
time to expect a man to propose like
honestly i'd say most relationships
nowadays like they don't get married
until like at least at least five maybe
even like 10 or 15 years to consider
getting on his knee
no way
would you would you say basically that
can't be right so would you say that um
in fact i watched an alexander grace
video the other day uh going over
exactly this topic and
it's strange the uh comparison from the
situation now compared to what it was
like uh 50 to 60 years ago so 50 to 60
years ago
men like were pretty much like were
willing to get married like within the
first year of of um forming a uh not i
think
was it going on the first day i don't
know the exact uh terms of the study but
it showed that
men were much more willing to comply
about getting married like
early on compared to what the situation
is now where
um men are delaying or apparently
delaying the onset of wanting to get
married they would they would rather
stay in a 10 to 15-year relationship
before um like knowing for certain that
they want to get married with a woman
were there guys having sex with the
girls before they were married at that
time because i know if this was like 50
to 60 years ago you said
yeah
oh i'm sorry i said about that so so the
data basically showed that so the basic
the data is basically showing that um
men are less likely to want to get
married um
now compared to uh 60 years ago and you
think that's because of the courts
basically because of the lack of legal
protection for men
yeah yeah i would say yeah it's mainly
because of that reason
i i've always thought it was more
because of the development of birth
control so then essentially you're
living as a married couple without
having the consequence of possibly
having a kid
um i'm not sure i'm a bit confused
so i'm saying like before um like my
grandma's generation people didn't
typically like live together before they
were married
um yeah so it's more common nowadays
yeah and it's more common nowadays but
why are they able to do that because the
development of birth control so you can
have you can have like be intimate now
and not have a kid
yeah whereas before like that was that
was in the cards like you could possibly
get pregnant
so so
it intensifies men to get married
earlier or
yeah i would think it would incentivize
you to get married earlier and date a
little bit more seriously on both ends
because there's the consequence of a
possible child
um
yeah yeah i guess there is like a some
extent to that argument but it could be
my argument it could be an element of
both uh but like i think we'll have to
do more research in
looking into today to see what that has
to say about it
uh i just want to move on to something
else because i found this really like
hilarious as well
i i think
what this when i hear people say
uh the argument men are the gatekeepers
of relationships
this is what comes to mind and i think
this sums up the dating scene so
accurately uh right now in 2021 so like
we have a man of the woman right here
like what did you say both of them just
quickly out of 10.
uh the girl may be a seven eight
uh then how about you
uh how tall is he
or just this is not entirely sure like
that's yeah well you don't know if the
woman's on heels or anything like that
but
i don't know
there's not much information here let's
just say maybe five five i would say
maybe six
okay so i would say
this guy about
five to six like he's got a narrowing
lower thirds um like he he's not bad
like his eye areas yeah like quite good
he's got curved upper lids like his
eyebrows are too end shaped which he's
giving a slightly effeminate appearance
in his eye area and of course he has a
narrowing lower third so that is why he
appears a bit softer but i was still
like he looks quite healthy his
hairline's good uh he's his teeth are
straight and like
uh white
i don't think he has that many
issues going on i i'd probably agree
that he's about five to
six but you might get i bet some people
in the comments of my videos will say
that he's a four or three but i would
say he's about five
pushing six
you said that the woman was a seven i
would say she's closer to about a five
okay i would say both of these are like
a similar sort of looks match
um
feel free to leave in the comments if
you think that these are
like if either of these two people were
a couple which one you would think is
punching or
i'm just gonna have a look
this is how i um rank like um looks
basically so
i i rank like body one to ten and then
uh for girls and face one to ten divided
by two guys i do the same thing with
height in their face
so
one more time
so
you rank like a woman's body from one to
ten like how in shape she is yeah and
you drink her face one to ten how in
shape she is or like how pretty her face
is and then you divide it by two
i mean this is just rough i haven't like
totally thought this completely through
but this is just like roughly because
when a girl's in shape that like makes
her higher up
and the guy like i do the same thing
with height
does that make sense yeah i say hi like
if i was going to put numbers on it i'd
say that like for men it's 50 face
30 height 20 body but for women i would
say it's like
50 face 40
body
10 right
that's what i say and so i'd give her a
seven because she looks then
like but you still like like there's not
a lot of weight by her face does that
make sense yeah i'm just looking at the
comments right now and they're mostly
saying about five
fives
okay both yeah it looks matched um yeah
they're mostly saying about five or so
yeah five six like same as me so i i
would just say that these like both two
looks match people um
and
but what's interesting is if we look at
this bit because this is like the main
point
he says we look so much like a couple
here
and then she says oh a couple of besties
so from the situation like we have a
hand it looks like the man is
um thinking that they are both
compatible for a potential relationship
but the woman is not willing to comply
like quite evidently i think that she
has friend-zoned him
so i think this is the issue with the
idea of men are the gatekeepers of
relationships because i would say
these two people who i'd say are looks
matched the woman is withholding the
possibility of a relationship compared
to the like the other way around it's
not the man withholding it
okay yeah no that's a good point
yeah and i would say
when women are using the term um
men of the gatekeepers of relationships
they're referring to
a man significantly below her no
significantly above sorry her level so
this woman like this is complete
speculation here but i would say this
situation that we have going on the man
probably thinks that they're a good
match like he's probably simply over her
to some extent like he's the type of guy
who's gonna pick up her from work like
to and from work every day like just as
a favor like not expecting anything
returned like he's a bit of a white
knight and i think this show's in the
message that he said as well
and the woman's probably able to get
hookups with
men significantly above her looks level
and she's probably thinking in her mind
that oh why can't i just get if i can
only just get commitment from one of
those guys and eight or nine like if i
can just get the commitment from that
guy like the chad who's not willing to
kill it i can just get a commitment from
him then i won't have an issue and i
think that is why she is friendzoning uh
this man because of her lack of
perspective of her own self
yeah no i think that's true
i've been thinking a little deeper it is
now because the fact that you said uh
that this woman
is a seven
like uh i would say
it's quite widespread that
women overestimate their appearance
more than men do would you agree with
that yeah i agree with that like i
watched a video the other day and
this is
the guy basically said that every woman
nowadays thinks she's a ted
oh my gosh no they totally do
yeah
i don't think that's like
so what would you say that is like what
would you say the main reasons for that
well well when i learned like i see it's
so hard because
i i see some things in the manual sphere
in real life and i know in the
manuscript they want you to like quote
study after study after study and i'm
not going to pretend like i can do that
i just kind of compare to what i see in
real life um
so i've definitely like in college
environments seem like the 2080 rule
where it's like 20
of the guys have access to like 80 of
the women but i've also seen girls like
simp over guys that are like
like short and going nowhere you know
what i mean
so but i complain that with a good face
so like take um
what's that got his name from
um
twilight he's quite short um but like
he's about like eight nine out of ten in
the face and yeah women are still like
simping over him to a large extent
because he is like
so far superior in his face
um
yeah probably you're probably right
so
i was just going to say like my
the reason i think that this is
partially happening is because this
woman
i again this is speculation but i say
this woman overestimates her
attractiveness
one
because she is able to get hookups with
men significantly below above her own
level two on social media
on instagram like whenever she posts
she's likely gonna get like hundreds of
her you know likes on it and she's gonna
get all of her best mates and even a few
men like telling her how gorgeous she is
uh that she's stunning like
she's you go girl like pretty much that
sort of thing and she probably sees the
same on tinder like she's getting
hundreds and hundreds of matches and
um she probably would reflect on that
and think this must be uh evidence that
like i'm very attractive
yeah no that's probably true
but i would also would you also say that
um
that is true for the majority of women
yeah probably yeah i think i think most
girls have symptoms like somewhere in
their life yeah
um yeah i i'd even say i'd even go as
far to say like 90 to 95 of women will
have like plenty of options like dozens
and dozens of options because men are
willing to
date down a lot of the time in
their looks level
so like uh if you take like a six out of
ten like he's he's probably gonna talk
to the three or a four uh simp over her
because he's he's not getting chances
with the people on his looks level
oh because they're aiming higher
yeah those girls are aiming higher
yeah i think um i'm not sure if you've
heard of this other channel but have you
heard of face in lms
no i've never heard i think he put it a
i think that he worded it perfectly he
said that dating for women
dating for women is a race at the top
but dating for men is a race to the
bottom
yeah
so it's kind of it's kind of like just
this cyclical effect i think that we're
having that um like women so men are
dating down because they're not getting
feedback from their own uh sort of like
looks match and then women are
reflecting on that and thinking that
they can achieve higher and their men
and then because of men are getting
um feedback from the women below their
looks level they're then willing to date
even lower and it's just this like
cyclical effect that we're seeing that
men are willing to stoop lower and lower
and lower their standards more and more
just to um
get intimacy pretty much
do you think that um
girls when they want to get married they
end up like finding someone on their
level or do you think they tend to marry
up to or stay single
in my opinion this is gonna sound like a
little bit bleak but i would say
women
um end up
marrying somebody close or slight
slightly above their looks match
but that is not because um like she is
willing to do that it is because a woman
so say if a woman starts off as like a
six or a seven
by the time she hits 30 to 35 like she's
her looks reduces down to like a
five like that's just the natural aging
process
and then like because men age slower
like now the fives who have built status
and wealth look more viable and she's
looking for somebody to
um
a partner to secure
and somebody to potentially like start a
family with raised a child
but she spent like the majority of her
best years her youth years chasing
somebody potentially out of her league
but she's more like more or less she's
waiting for her looks to decline and
then realizing that she's not got as
many options as she once had and then
she might be willing to settle a bit
more
so i think that but that would be that
would be for women that get married
older right would you say the average
age of marriage is dramatically
increasing i don't know the exact
numbers again but it's 27 yeah it's 27.
are you sure
it's 27 for women 28 for men um
according i just googled it the last
time probably in the last month um i
didn't double check triple check the
source for anything i just figured
that's probably right so if you find
something more credible if you're
welcome it's our first first marriage
first marriage
50 of marriage has ended divorce and
most people get remarried after that so
i'd still say there's a large chunk of
women who maybe um
settle early with their first marriage
have a child like split up after a
couple years and then get remarried with
um somebody lower smv uh in their mid
thirties because
i don't think that's ignorable because
there is such a large portion of women
that are getting married older uh no
divorcing which would in turn cause them
to
uh
be thrown back into the dating pool in
their mid-30s
huh um oh you're right and 80 to 90
percent of women initiate divorces which
is something i did not know before i
think it's 80 i think it's 70 percent of
divorces are initiated by women
oh is that i heard 80 percent
eight eighty percent i think it's
depending on the country as well like i
live in the uk so
i believe it's 70 but but even so like
the point is uh that
women are the ones not getting satisfied
in their
marriages
because otherwise yeah so they're the
ones who are initiating it they're the
ones who are not happy
uh and yeah want to divorce